ich bin da stieg stefan 23 jahre alt und
kommt aus niederösterreich
ich bin stationiert bei der bewaffneten
mehrzweckhubschrauber staffel in langen
leben am fliegerhorst romanowski
eingerückt bin ja oktober 2016
die entscheidung dass sie dort so die
hubschrauber will ist eigentlich schon
bei der musterung freuen
generell immer schon sehr technisch
interessiert waren macht auf monitor
einer kundin war das ganz lässig das
motto jeder und das ist und was nicht
meine funktion ist als assistenz
techniker in der luftfahrt das heißt wir
sahen unterstützend für die piloten beim
stadtdienst für die maschinen zum
herrichten in der früh und bei die
wartungen zivis arbeiten waren wir mal
herkommen in der früh dann fragen wir
mal was für hubschrauber er kriegt
werden vom stadtdienst dass wir wissen
was überhaupt ausgetreten wird einmal
maschinen abdeckt wasser geschaut ob im
bank am oster drinnen ist gestern alles
hergerichtet haben wir uns aus action
und meistens haben wir eh unter docs im
erwartungen oder sonst irgendwelche
allfälligen aufgaben und wären dann das
operetten bis zum schluss
vorher habe an kfz mechaniker mit system
electronic arts abgeschlossen und
freundlich bei unserer man sehr gut weil
es eben muss einzigartiges ist damit
jeder die chance dazu hat überlegt
rheuma schaffe die büros oder miliz und
mir hat es ganz einfach es ist alles im
lot
immer setzen die festung machen für die
karte präsent einheit und wir dann man
die positiv abgeschlossen ist und was
mit leyen rücke die bahn zu präsentieren
übernommen